hi i'm carlos pleasure to meet you nice
to meet you
you got to tell me about the experience
of stepping out onto that stage in front
of all those people like the first few
steps when you actually get to see them
see you for the first time and they're
excited about this thing
oh yeah yeah but i'm incredibly british
so it's like don't trip up
uh find your seat
exceedingly british that's all i can
think about is what i need to do in the
moment on the day one step in front of
other no it's um i feel like actually
the whole comic con has been like i
think one the fact that
there hasn't
been as many comic cons recently and
then the anticipation equally of the
sandman 30 years the first it's the
first time this comic book is actually
going to make it to screen um and also
from what i've seen and how excited i
feel about it so it's got it does feel
like that real um
it feels great for it finally to be you
know being put out into the world what
was it that made you excited about it
like when you first heard about the
opportunity i think um
because i'd never read the comic books
before but i the images were ingrained
in my mind so obviously somewhere
in my own consciousness i've been i've
picked that up somewhere but i think
neil gaiman's imagination and and the
the visual
language in that show and creatively
like what that how to how to explore
that it just feels it's so distinctive
and it's so distinctive like
distinctively gaming as well and so
distinctively it's it's kind of own
genre
um so yeah that's that's that's what
excited me how would you describe uh
joanna constantine and and the
relationship do you have with dream
um i would say joanna constantine is
like a tough dry roguish
cynic
but deep down inside is kind of a lone
tortured
warrior a lone wolf doesn't really like
to let people close very armored and
where she meets dream is obviously the
one place where she's at her most
vulnerable which is in her dreams that
he can see so it's it kind of she's not
very easily impressed by people so
meeting someone like dream of the
endless who is used to people bowing at
his feet but she doesn't do that so it's
this kind of this battle of the wit this
kind of mutual admiration and respect
yet this stubbornness to admit there's
any admiration and respect and
it was a really fun uh it was a really
fun pairing and working with tom in
particular and seeing his
how how he embodied dream was uh and
working from that as a as an actor
playing opposite him was really great
because he's it's like he's completely
captured something other yeah have you
had a chance to see the whole series i
have not yet
no so because it's interesting like the
setup is interesting you have not all
been in scenes together like he is the
connective tissue between all of you
he's a connective tissue so this makes
it one of the weirdest kind of um
press junkets because you're meeting
you're like hello nice to meet you kirby
who i met today who's playing death who
i was sat next to so it's great because
there's so much for me to um enjoy as a
fan um but yeah the anthology kind of
nature nature of it is is is kind of
bizarre was there anything that neil
said to you or to the cast at all that
kind of set you on your course for this
um nothing in particular but neil being
very much there from the first um
like our first read through me and tom
got together in a room he was in new
zealand so we were on skype zooms
together and then and then alan was like
again constantly fine-tuning the script
as as we went all of the time so um
it was it was a really good kind of
creative process to get what we got on
screen i'm super excited i know a lot of
people are too thank you for the time